[Music]
what do you
i'm gonna show you some photos all right
so check out this guy
all right
three seconds one
two three they look like the same
person it is it is it is the same person
that is
one guy
um and then this guy what do these guys
have in common
oh [__] what what the [__] that guy's
nose is melt off
don't tell me does he did it did he get
an acid attack or some kind of accident
don't tell me that that he's the [__]
donor for the transplant that those
other dudes have
closed
oh [__] he some skin graft [__] he is
okay
we built his face did this guy become
the
nose-off the nose-off guy became this
guy no song
this is actually a former soldier who
was involved in a terrible accident not
in the war or anything like that but
that's the worst yeah and has shown
the remarkable transformation he's made
since having a face transplant wow face
transplant that's [__] nicholas cage
face-off dude yeah so old reference so
42-year-old mitch hunter has uh hailed
his surgery as the best decision he's
ever made and can hardly believe how
good it looks he was just 21 when he was
involved in a car crash after a night
out crashing into an electric pylon
carrying 10 000 volts
so he got electrocuted and crashed
shoving a female passenger out of the
way he suffered severe burns to his face
hands and legs oh he's he was saving
somebody
dude
he endured the pain of the electrical
current for five full minutes he got no
five minutes of getting [__] shot this
guy's a badass dude that's crazy after
two months on hospital he was released
but has since had 67 facial
reconstruction surgeries
this is like some superhero origin [__]
electro man or something this dude went
67 times to get a procedure done holy
special reconstruction surgery yeah
now around a decade later he became only
the second person in the usa to have a
face transplant honestly he looked like
just a regular [__] guy yeah
seriously his face did he borrow after
receiving his donor face from a dead
person he has now shown off the full
extent of his transformation so i don't
know about borrow
but a debt or this is what happens when
you put a
donor sticker on your driver's license
somebody's gonna jack your face
you know it's
it's interesting that um they found
someone of his ethnic background because
imagine if whoever was available at the
moment was another
race and you just have to look like this
guy or somebody just did a clerical
error and just sent a different face
yeah suddenly that was a forever racial
slur would that be a black face if he
got a black guy's it would literally be
a black face i think but um which was a
woman's face that'd be pretty cool well
how about like the family of the
person's face that they're using like
now they see it on another person that's
got to be [__] up that's gonna be wild
or what if he got the face of a guy that
signed off his image to stock photos and
now he's getting sued all the time
or he's getting money all the time yeah
it's got a 3d printed face so it has
those weird 3d printing ridges
the lines all over it just feels like it
too it just looks like a big-ass
thumbprint
i wonder if you could just get the skin
and mold and shape it differently so it
doesn't look like is that what do you
think happened because it kind of does
like can i see the pictures again
absolutely my friend that makes me oh
that's crazy right there dude wait does
he have does he have facial hair
the other one the the the after
damn he looks young right now this has
come along a lot that's pretty cool you
remember that chick who got her face
ripped off by the monkey yeah
and then they replaced her face
like this the monkeys this is so
different he has facial hair
this is crazy right that's it's crazy
he just looks like he just looks like a
dick he looks great
he looks like he's in [__] quest he
looks like a dead man he does you with
the hair
the cool ass hair yeah this guy's a star
yeah yeah let's uh let's play a little
video it does i think once you know and
then you watch a video of him like
speaking and stuff and you kind of see
like
not everything looks like it's fully
connected there's no
yeah i mean it's still amazing where it
came from you know this is some internet
commenter [__]
he looks like [__] he thinks his face
looks good it doesn't
i don't want to say it but he looks like
[__] you got so much sass i love it
right
now i'm thinking what steve just said
[Music]
so
one of the main questions i've been
getting asked about my face transplant
is
what happened to my face
um i was a passenger in a pickup truck
it was a driver his girlfriend me the
driver lost control around a telephone
pole
and smacked into a cracked in half
um when the other passenger got out she
got hit by one of the wires i got out i
got hurt off the wire and then i got hit
it was ten thousand volts seven amps for
five minutes
hey kids story time
so i had an ironic story about the
knight and you guys so i still think
it's pretty decent you can kind of see
that not everything feels like fully
like where the eyes are it looks like as
if like in a movie set or something like
that when they put some like a
prosthetic yeah
so i'll move forward a little bit i
think he shows a couple dude that's
pretty cool yeah there it is
that is crazy from that
he sounds just like a regular dude
oh so this is like as he's getting it
like fixed yeah
oh so he totally did become a different
[__] guy yeah the new face is just
like someone else that's amazing i want
to see
what the previous guy's face looked like
yeah well i mean the guy that he got the
face from yeah and then what he looked
like before zach cox man [__] yeah dude
let's go in he's the colts fan yeah
his face gets younger that's crazy yeah
like foreign
it looks like he was five different
people yeah wow that's great to me it's
still crazy that electricity did that i
know you would think like fire or
something like that but the electricity
i can't believe that he can grow hair
and everything that's something yeah
a great beard i can't grow a beer i
can't i could never connect like that
yeah i could never make it doesn't
connect well just get a new face i guess
so
it's a thing yeah but it's first come
first serve hey
would you wizard yourself
what's that would your beard would you
do a wizard's beard like just grow it
like how long can you grow no this is i
mean this is already bad i mean i like
ice cream so it [__] everything up
but you can eat it with a spoon
yeah but then i'm gonna look like a
[__] [__] you got an ice cream cone
with a spoon you can't drink ice cream
through a straw but then you do look
like a little coffee
[Laughter]
[__] like a little bit yeah for sure
what's the longest you had your beard
for a little longer than this but can
you get yeah it'll go with [__] kung
fu master it yeah youtube i don't know
mine grows
this way oh i know yeah so i don't i
don't think so like a rabbi yeah it just
gets really thick and then slowly grows
so yeah you do that around
a year but it'd probably only be like
down here because like even when it gets
really long i can pull it and it's
really long but when you let go it
immediately comes oh you're curly yeah
does it make a cartoon sound new ink
that's my hair
i'm going to try to so
yeah
he talks about how i barely remember
anything from when the wires touched my
face one minute i was helping the
injured girl trying to get her away from
the pole the next i was in the hospital
nearly a month later wow i knew my
injuries were serious when my mom and
stepmom were in the room consulting one
another because they usually hated each
other
for a few days no one would show me a
mirror until my ex-girlfriend at the
time came to visit and brought one with
her and then she woke up the
ex-girlfriend was like
i got a mirror for you
what a jerk so it was his girlfriend at
the time or ex-girlfriend at the time he
said ex-girlfriend at the time
says i can't describe the feeling i had
when seeing myself like that it didn't
feel real i was unrecognizable the girl
i saved only had minor burns to her foot
but i suffered full thickness burns on
every inch of my face along with my
hands and right leg hey he looked like
um skeletor huh he did
like voldemort this guy was a military
guy ex-military yeah so he probably has
buddies that are [__] with him
because he don't like that oh for sure
so he must have been like how do i look
and like no one knows yeah you know that
you know it that's so true they were
probably [__] with them so bad you
look better than you looked last week
there's an improvement a lot of that
[__] dude the military bus balls like
that
i want military guys without having to
serve for my country
let's just be military guys now let's
just say we're just military guys
we'll just say we are stolen
that's one of my favorite things to
watch on youtube people because
yeah i call out all these fake veterans
and [__] yeah there's a guy in like the
senate who's a total faker really yeah
dude you said he was a vietnam veteran
he's totally full of [__] is he still
he's still in there yeah
what did you still rep it you can pay to
stay in office you just have to have
enough signs up of your name on it [__]
isn't that such an easy thing to dox or
like verify yeah yeah they did but
nobody cares damn
but they cared when that girl was fake
sign language getting on the tv oh my
god but get her off there
you gotta love how fake sign language
you know also you nail some words too
yeah you're saying something yeah it's
like well and then he spun her around
and it's like this and it's like that's
fun
or whatever
well that's the funny thing is you're
never a fake signer you're just a bad
one
doing it
that's not good
that's true i like i like how the stolen
valor people always get caught because
of something really like their belt was
wrong or something because you know like
you always have to have the outfit like
exact or like the wrong socks so that's
how they find them
or the the best is the gun community
when they find that you don't have good
trigger control or whatever in the
picture
why do you have your trigger on your
finger on the chain what the [__] that's
not proper gun safety i'll [__] kill
you
i'll kill you
i'll execute you
and it's usually on something like this
like a toy gun or some [__]
like a [__] nerf gun dude i'm gonna
murder you before you kill someone
guys yeah yeah man see
[Music]